[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія Суперба, і
настав час нашого уроку англійської мови, тож
давайте поговоримо про їжу, тому що ми знаємо, що якщо
ми будемо вживати здорову їжу, то будемо здоровими
на попередньому уроці, ми дізналися
багато різних видів  продуктів, які ми поміщаємо
їх у харчову піраміду, щоб знати, як їсти
здорову їжу, як отримати збалансовану
дієту, яку ми приготували, і вона буде грати, і
ми знаємо, що станеться, якщо ми не будемо
пити достатньо води щодня,
тому на останньому уроці ми  ходили по магазинах зі
списком покупок, ми читаємо етикетки
різних продуктів і порівнюємо,
який вибрати, а також у вас був домашній
тест, давайте зараз перевіримо його, тому ваше домашнє
завдання полягало в тому, щоб написати речення зі
словами і записати їх добре, тому я даю
ви правильні варіанти, і ви
перевірите свої варіанти добре номер один
наш вчитель хоче, щоб ми щодня говорили англійською.
Хороший номер два померла Хеленс
хотіла, щоб вона спробувала плінкс
минулої ночі. Ось чому ми
хотіли в минулому  як
це зображення пельменів номер три
Пітер хотів, щоб Рой грав у футбол
учора, це також у минулому,
тому ми хотіли, а номер четвертий Дженні
хоче, щоб вони щодня добре грали в теніс,
тому на останньому уроці ми
дізналися, що є
багато нехороших добавок у продуктах, які ми
зазвичай купуємо в супермаркеті, тому
ми можемо вирощувати їжу в нашому саду, а
це історія від нашої подруги з
Великобританії, щоб пам'ятати Сашу, вона
розповідає свою історію про свій сад, тому
слухайте  її та подивіться відео
[Музика]
це оновлення саду цього тижня
насіння проросло подивіться, як далеко
вони зайшли, я думаю, що цього року у нас
буде багато полуниці,
коли ви посадили в цьому місці, багато маленьких білих квітів  овоч, співробітниця,
зняла кабачок і подивіться на це, а ми
посадили цибулю-латук і цибулю фенхелю,
а також ці великі рослини на минулорічній
картоплі, ці розсади квасолі
зараз дійсно великі, тому вони готові
до великого  грядка дивіться завдяки кращій
погоді готові до посадки зараз наші
помідори огірки перець та
баклажани
що це таке сеанс дивіться Rena beam
[Музика]
так молодець Саша і я хочу, щоб ми подивилися
на цей слайд з деякими новими словами, можливо,
ви чули в  це відео посадити
рослину расулину посадити Стрільця
Адіті
добре прорости Гемініди красива
зебра починає щітку Вікі Кара я
обробляю сад оновлення оновлюю сад це бачення asado technoServe at asana
vido це оновлення саду грядка грядка
це не те, де ви спите, а  де
саша садить грядку
graça насіння массена паросток живлення
коренеплід каренія стебла удар і залишити
rista ваше завдання буде послухати ще раз
і сказати, які рослини саша саша
росте в її саду я дам
вам підказку, що є деякі  з них,
наприклад, вона садить віяло фенхелю,
він пом'ятиме кушет-каппа-
душку та пюре з цибулі-порею
Мулла-пюре, яку вона садить, вони в
Сашіному саду, так що бу  Ви послухайте цю
історію ще раз і запишіть назви
овочів, які саджає Саша, я
думаю, що цього року у нас буде
багато полуниці, багато
маленьких білих квіточок, коли ви посадили в
цей овоч, щоб все ще потиснути та
погуляти  але ми посадили цибулю-
латук і цибулю фенхелю, і ці великі рослини
на минулорічній картоплі, ці
розсада квасолі зараз дійсно велика, тож вони
готові вийти на велику грядку, а
завдяки кращій погоді, зараз готові до посадки
помідори  огірки перець і
поверх джинсів
що це за сесія дивіться Rena beam
[Музика]
так у Саші такий гарний сад, то
давайте подивимося на ці фотографії, і, можливо,
вони допоможуть вам мати власний
сад, це різні етапи
посадки салату, але вони виправилися  дозвольте
мені прочитати це для вас, а потім ви повинні
розмістити їх у правильному порядку d
рослина росте і починає
пускати листя Піскотті найменше повинен листя та
збирати врожай салату останнє
Arai salato  насіння починає
проростати і рости з насіння,
тому що воно стає паростком
II далі листи розвиваються на рослині
і утворюють салат
Ліза для настрою овочі салат а
за допомогою води можна поливати насіння моря
що це все добре  і G висаджують
насіння в ґрунт, подібний до ґрунту, тож
я даю вам трохи часу, і ви повинні розмістити
їх у правильному порядку, і ми побачимо,
що ми отримаємо,
якщо розмістимо їх у правильному порядку, у нас
буде чудовий сад у наступному
завдання доповнити текст наступними
словами серце домашні інгредієнти джерело
свіжі готові вітаміни та добавки
добре я прочитаю текст для вас, а
ви заповните пропуски минулого тижня, до
речі, це історія про кулінарний
досвід гарне приготування їжі  з
однієї дівчини минулого тижня я приготував вечерю для
своєї сім'ї я пішов у супермаркет і
купив усі їхні інгредієнти, ви можете
купити їжу в супермаркеті,
які страви ви можете купити якісь страви
в супі  ermarket але в них часто
багато цукру і в них, як ви
думаєте, про що вона говорить про
готові ну добре і часто в них
багато цукру та добавок добавок
осел далі я хотів приготувати
здорову страву, тому купив багато
над овочами які овочі
вона купила так свіжі овочі свіжі
овочі у них багато, тому
вони дуже корисні для вас, що у них
багато так, ветерани я отримав
рис із карими очима, тому що це добре, для кого
зерно, це хороше джерело  цільнозернових,
які корисні для вашого серця
так, пам'ятайте, цільні зерна корисні для
вашого серця, я хотів, щоб це була особлива
вечеря, тому ми мали, який торт у
них є решта останній
домашній пиріг
так домашній пиріг теж моя мама  і тато
сказав, що мій пиріг був
смачний  s text,
це проблеми з піцою, добре, якщо ви
жахливий кухар, вам сподобається ця історія
минулого місяця, моя мама купила мені
книгу рецептів, рецепти виглядали легко, тому я
вирішив приготувати піцу на вечерю одного
вечора, я купив інгредієнти, а
потім почав готувати  приготувати хліб для
піци я змішав борошно, сіль і воду в
мисці, я слухав музику по
радіо, було дуже голосно, тому я не почув, як
мій брат зайшов на кухню, він
вигукнув моє ім'я і налякався мене, я
впустив м'яч  бо підлога і вода пролилась
по всій
команді підлогу і мої штани, на щастя, моя
сім'я подумала, що моя кулінарна катастрофа була
дуже смішною, ми пішли в піцерію
на вечерю,
з тих пір я більше не готував, якщо я
знову буду готувати, я не буду  слухай музику
на кухні добре, і тепер ви можете побачити,
що це історія про поганий
досвід у кулінарії, і це мудро,
і назва - проблеми з піцою,
тому дайте відповідь на моє запитання,
що хотіла зробити Тіна, що хотіла зробити Тіна,
так  ви можете бачити, що вона
w  хотіла приготувати піцу, тому що вона думала, що
це дуже легко так, і чому Інна не
прийшла сюди, її брат не прийшов на кухню,
чому вона не почула, чому так,
тому що вона слухала музику і
музика була дуже голосною, музика була дуже
голосною, добре, це  тип тексту - це
особистий обліковий запис, у якому ми можемо написати в
Інтернеті про якусь цікаву історію,
і в кінці цього тексту можуть бути
різні кінцівки, як-от перше,
як люди відчували, на щастя, моя сім'я
подумала, що моя кулінарна катастрофа була дуже
смішною або і що сталося  зрештою
, щоб розповісти про те, що сталося, ми пішли в
піцерію на вечерю і кілька
коментарів про те, що сталося і
що письменник дізнався після цієї історії,
я більше не готував відтоді, і якщо я буду
готувати знову, я не буду слухати музику  на
кухні, тож це коментар,
а завдання полягає в тому, що тепер давайте
зіставимо кінцівки та тип кінцівок, як
люди відчули те, що сталося в кінці,
і коментарі до історії коментарі
до історії, перший рядок, якщо я
вирішу  щоб знову здивувати маму, я
зроблю листівку, це набагато безпечніше, номер два.
Я купив мамі торт на день народження в
пекарні, і ми всі насолоджувалися її святковим днем народження, а т
етім, моя мама засміялася, коли по
ула про мої пригоди на ку
ні, до
обачення  але я відчував себе дуже нерозумно, тому поєднай ці
три рядки добре, я дам тобі трохи часу,
і відповідність буде такою, добре,
якщо я знову вирішу здивувати маму, я можу
пропустити кошик,
це коментарі до історії, я купив
торт для розуму,
це  те, що сталося в кінці кінців,
і я відчував себе дуже дурним, це те, що
люди думали про те, що трапилося, і
тепер ми дуже близькі до того, щоб щось приготувати,
але нам потрібно знати кілька
слів про кулінарію, тому у мене є
кілька зображень, які описують
дії на кухні та кілька слів
про опис цієї картини, і ви
повинні відповідати їм нарізати випікати шкірку смажити
скибочку збити та відварити, тому поєднайте їх, і у
нас буде так, як
це збиває яйця варять
очищення відрізають, коли ми щось ріжемо  скибочки,
коли ми нарізаємо скибочки, смажимо та
запікаємо, але це ще не кінець, ми
повинні розташувати їх у правильному порядку, щоб мати
рецепт, так, завдання полягає в тому, що ви повинні
розмістити їх у правильному порядку, щоб приготувати
іспанський омлет, добре, я даю вам  деякий
час і розташуйте їх у правильному порядку, що у нас
вийде так номер один ми повинні
почистити картоплю номер два зварити
три картоплі відварити і три нарізати
цибулю скибочками Помідори збити яйця і обсмажити
або запекти омлет так, насправді у нас
є рецепт з інгредієнтами  і
інструкція або метод, як це зробити, так що
для іспанського омлету нам знадобиться 4 яйця для
картоплі одна цибулина два помідори чотири
столові ложки оливкової олії і трохи солі
для двох людей на дві порції методи
тепер
вставте слова в пропуски, і ви
вже знаєте  це слово спочатку те, що
ми робимо спочатку так, ми очищаємо картоплю,
потім кладемо її в каструлю і варимо протягом
п'яти хвилин,
далі нарізаємо цибулю і нарізаємо помідори,
а картоплю на рівні шматочки,
парні шматочки.  у Akiko Suzuki
вниз тепер збийте яйця і додайте
трохи солі, перемішайте все разом у
мисці, потім обсмажте суміш на сковороді
з олією до готовності з обох сторін,
або ви можете запекти в духовці,
так що це кінець нашого уроку  Ви можете
використовувати цей рецепт, щоб приготувати іспанський омлет
вдома, а також для вас є домашнє завдання,
перше, яке ви повинні зробити принаймні,
які рослини Саша росте у своєму
саду та використайте історію, але створіть свій
власний фінал цієї історії про піцу
проблеми, тож дуже дякую і будьте
здорові та щасливі
[Музика].